Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show.
I'm Farron Cousins and I'm going to be sitting
in for David for these next two days. We've
got a lot to cover today. Of course, we've had
more from the January six committee.
We've had more from the documentary film
that is now a central piece of evidence in those
hearings. We're going to be talking about all
that. Plus, Marjorie Taylor Green's week long
meltdown, among many other stories. So let's
jump right into it. And I want to start by, of
course, talking about the January six hearings
and the big takeaway that I have had from
all of these hearings we have seen so far
everything that's come out of the committee
and pretty much anything that's been revealed
since January 6th of 2021 is that had Donald
Trump had a more competent team working for him,
I think his coup would have gone a lot differently
and not, of course, in a good way for the United
States. So think about this for a moment. One of
the things we learned earlier this week was that
Mark Meadows was actually actually offering state
officials free MAGA stuff, including autographed
MAGA gear. If officials were, you know, willing
to toss out their state's 2020 election results.
Not exactly a big selling point, right? Yeah.
Like, hey, we know what's unconstitutional. We
know you're going to have to break the law, but
we're going to throw in a free hat. How does that
sound? Right. Nobody in their right mind is going
to take that offer. And then, of course, we have
Mike Lindell, who has been spearheading the
efforts to overturn the 2020 election results
to this very day. Attorneys like Sidney
Powell and John Eastman and Rudy Giuliani,
all of this cast of just absolute weirdos.
Working to overturn the 2020 election,
and all of them, in my opinion, equally
incompetent. And that's the thing, though.
Had any of these individuals been switched out by
somebody that maybe actually knew what they were
doing? You know, somebody with a little bit of a
brain in their heads, Trump could have succeeded,
you know, switch out. Sidney Powell and
Rudy Giuliani and substitute in Bill Barr.
Suddenly that becomes a lot scarier if the
attorney general of the United States had gone
along with this plan. He would have been able
to use the power of the DOJ. There would have
been enough people inside the DOJ to try to carry
out these plans. Think for a second. If instead of
Mike Lindell going out there and selling this to
the public, which hasn't gone very well for him.
What if it was Karl Rove instead? Things would
have been a lot different. Rove is a master at
messaging. He's an expert manipulator. Whereas,
of course, Mike Lindell just comes across,
as you know, a bit of an unhinged kind of
guy. He's the pillow man, for God's sakes.
But you switch out any one of these little weirdos
for somebody with even a little bit of competence.
A little bit of credibility. Suddenly we're
looking at a very different scenario in the
United States today. And, of course, therein lies
the bigger problem for the future. Donald Trump,
of course, and all other Republicans who might
be planning something similar. They've all
learned from these mistakes, right? They know the
kind of people that they need to put in place.
And how do we know that they've learned from this?
Well, you need look no further than Steve Bannon.
For more than a year now, ever since Trump left
office, really on his podcast, Steve Bannon
has been one of the leading cheerleaders telling
these MAGA folks out here across the country,
go run for office, go become a poll worker.
Run for secretary of state. Run for governor.
Put yourselves in the position. To where this, you
know, the allegedly stolen 2020 election, which
wasn't stolen. But put yourself in the position to
where you can do something about it in the future.
The framework has been laid down. Okay. It's not
in the planning phases. The framework is there now
to a degree. Maybe not to enough of a degree to
actually overturn election results, but they're
getting close and there could be a heck of a lot
closer after this year's midterms. And it all goes
back to learning from their mistakes. They knew
or they know now. They didn't know at the time,
but they know now that the people they had running
this whole thing were wholly incompetent. So you
replace them with more competent individuals.
You replace them with people who know how to get
things done. You replace them with loyal lapdogs
who are not going to tell you no. That, of course,
has been one of Trump's driving factors with his
endorsements so far in the primary season. That's
why he tried so desperately to get Brian Kemp and
Brad Raffensperger out of the state of Georgia.
Because he wants people that would not tell
him no if he were to ask them to break the law.
And it's already happening. Again, not to not
to the degree that he would like to see it
or that other Republicans would
like to see it. But it is happening.
They know where their weak links
were in 2021, on January 6th.
And more and more of them, of course, are
being exposed by these January six hearings.
And they're not going to make the same mistake
twice. And again, that to me is where the real
danger lies. It's great that we're exposing
everything that happened that has to be done.
We also have to hold them criminally accountable
for it. But we can't. You know, once this is over,
wipe our hands. Cool. Case closed. We've saved
democracy. No. That threat is still out there.
And that, again, is kind of the underlying theme
of these hearings. It's been the underlying
theme also for the record of the judges
overseeing the cases of the Capitol rioters.
They have said that plenty of these people we've
seen how they've been essentially brainwashed.
And we believe it can happen again. We
believe these people are still dangerous.
That's why a lot of the judges overseeing these
cases have been annoyed when prosecutors, you
know, reduced the charges down to misdemeanors.
The judges want to put these people in jail.
Because they're afraid it's going to happen again.
We're getting reports from the Department of
Homeland Security. You know, to expect violence.
Another report came out yesterday warning of the
increased risk of violence here in the United
States as we head into the midterms. And all of
it goes back to January six, folks. Every bit of
it is tied back to that. Because all these people
from Trump down to his supporters and everybody
in between, they learned from their mistakes.
And it's unlikely that they would
be making those same mistakes again.